retour du journal le lundi retour des
résultats sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir et alors il y avait
notamment ce week-end michael un gros
match de hockey sur gazon
effectivement il y aurait je vois que
vous êtes toujours aussi assidus insu
résultats sportifs du week-end c'était
le choc de cette dernière journée élite
le racing club de france 4e recevait ce
dimanche 28 avril à versailles et le
stade français classé troisième après
une première période équilibrée les
locaux ont réussi à prendre l'ascendant
pour l'emporter sur le score de 5 à 2 on
écoute les réactions ça s'est plutôt
bien passé puisqu'on gagne 5,2 à deux
donc c'est plutôt un bon score on est
content du résultat
après sur la manière il ya quand même
des choses qui sont perfectibles
j'ai eu beaucoup d'erreurs techniques je
sais pas si c'est le terrain où notre
niveau d'implication mais beaucoup
d'erreurs techniques qui ont fait que
certaines occasions qu'ils étaient bien
mises en place n'ont pas pu aboutir
on avait à coeur de bien finir cette
saison contre une équipe sur lequel on
avait perdu
au match aller et du coup voilà on a on
a un petit peu rétabli les choses et
c'était important
avec cette victoire le racing club de
france terminent la phase régulière à la
quatrième place ils joueront en
demi-finale de play-off contre leurs
voisins de saint jean les samedi
prochain un derby
yves binois qu'on a hâte de voir on
continue de parler de versailles michael
mais cette fois ci du rugby les
versaillais l'ont fait les joueurs de la
cité royale ont remporté ce week-end de
boucliers deux titres de champion ile de
france
la réserve l'emportent 29 à 28 face aux
skull sur terrain neutre et l'équipe
première a réussi à battre vincennes sur
le score de 17 à 12
on écoute le responsable communication
du club pierre chevallier nous parle de
cette saison historique
prochain objectif pour aller vers ça y
est allé chercher un titre de champion
de france honneur dans les prochaines
semaines pour cela ils devront battre
lille ce dimanche sur terrain neutre
on termine par du golfe miquel un
événement qui ne vous est pas étranger
exactement j étais vous y étiez
également la ryder cup 2018 a été nommé
événement sportif de l'année à la
semaine dernière à londres par le
prestigieux bureau britannique de
l'industrie du sport le tournoi qui a vu
les européens s'imposer face aux états
unis sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines a accueilli près de
270 mille fans venus du monde entier fin
septembre l'événement également battu le
record d'articles parus dans la presse
écrite d'un milliard de personnes ont vu
cette ryder cup française à la
télévision
la prochaine édition aura lieu en 2020
dans le wisconsin aux états unis merci
michael on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants à la présentation du 7-8 sport
comme tous les lundis sur tv 78